good
morning time for work I don't think I'm
up to it I'm just not creatively
fulfilled in retail Josie we've talked
about this work isn't about fulfillment
it's about earning money so you can buy
stuff that makes you feel fulfilled I
think no no stop too much thinking no
wonder you feel a bit sad just have a
cup of tea pop some deodorant on and
stop thinking trust me stop thinking do
you see me thinking no it's not good for
you your brain is the enemy so just
stop can you try and smile a bit more
when you're with us Dev says he finds
you a haunting presence and I prefer if
his libido wasn't dragged down by your
face there she is ready for the big wide
world have you farted I can't do it in
my room dev's in
there